linked emails made it clear that the
2016 Democratic primary was rigged
against Bernie Sanders in favor of
Hillary Clinton now it's looking like
the 2020 race may have similar problems
tulsi gabbard has logged at least 2% in
several dozen polls but the DNC does not
want her on the debate stage and they're
claiming now that those polls aren't
certified polls so Gabbert likely won't
make the next round of primary debates
Michael Tracy has been following this
for the very beginning he's an
independent journalist and he joins us
tonight so I don't know exactly how many
of our viewers are gonna vote for tulsi
gabbard probably none but I think we can
all agree that tulsi gabbard is a
valuable voice and we should hear from
Tulsi Gabbard and it seems to me I don't
want to be paranoid but it sounds like
the Democratic Party they don't want her
voice included am I being a conspiracy
person bison by wondering that well you
might be surprised Tucker she does tend
to generate actually somewhat
significant support among even
conservatives and libertarians
notwithstanding effectively has a fairly
straightforward left-wing policy agenda
but she has something about her I don't
know ambience that draws a sort of
idiosyncratic range of support from
across the spectrum and I think that has
rubbed certain people the wrong way I'm
not going to allege a conspiracy as to
why she is likely going to be excluded
from the next debate but I am going to
allege that the criteria the DNC is
using to determine who is included and
who is excluded is laughably arbitrary
as I mentioned in an article that I
wrote this week in real clear politics
Gabbard has gotten over the required
polling threshold in two separate polls
in two separate early primary states the
Boston Globe is the newspaper with the
widest circulation in New Hampshire and
the Post and Courier is the newspaper
with the widest circulation in South
Carolina
gabber has gotten placed at two percent
or more in polls published by those two
newspapers but the DNC and it's bizarre
mysterious infinite wisdom has decreed
again arbitrarily that those polls are
not approved or they're not you know
they don't satisfy
some weird criteria that nobody can
quite ascertain so while I'm not going
to allege an over conspiracy although
it's true that everybody from Donna
Brazile to Elizabeth Warren alleged that
the previous primary cycle was quote
rigged but you'd be forgiven for having
that impression given how obscure and
sort of inscrutable the criteria that
the DNC is using this time around are
I'm not saying that tulsi necessarily
have special privileges and or that the
rules weren't laid out months ago which
they were but the rules don't seem to
hold up to any kind of logical scrutiny
at the problem and we know for a fact
they despise her because she's
challenged their neoconservative
assumptions about foreign policy and god
bless her for doing that Michael thanks
very much for joining us tonight thank
you